so I'm first I want to apologize because
as you can see I'm a services that is
currently turning into Data 70s so
probably there is too much physics in
this talk and not enough data science
for your face but what I recommendous to
to still make it Pleasant for you so the
idea is to use this knee to detect those
power arms of the Milky Way and you can
see on the top left photo for instance
at the beautiful guy to use power arms
and well it's easy when you have a photo
like that but already on this talk when
this Plateau as a galaxy is a bit
incline it's become very much more
difficult to to identify those poweramps
and something like that and it can even
be that you have a spiral galaxy with
not really well defines power arms and
then when
and in the Milky Way which is also a
spiral galaxy this is what you see
because since we are in the Milky Way
while we don't have external photos to
identify those Firearms so we have to do
it with well what we can do but just
clip this
perfect uh well we we cannot identify
those power Armstrong from the outside
so it's much more complicated actually
in our case
so the idea is while you use what you
have that is coordinates for four stars
or whatever objects you use and
distances
and you are kind of bound to Young
objects because otherwise they move from
their birthplace and then they evolve
away from those power arms and also the
spiral arms evolve with time so you you
need to use young objects and people
have done that with mazes so from the
acronym you can guess that it's an
extension of lasers but except that the
emitting is a microwave
and you find those in uh around
non-stellar objects that's basically
stars in forming so those are a few Mega
years and we know something like 200 in
the Milky Way and this these people read
it I'll have made this model of spiral
arms based on the detection of these
measures and what I did is using another
kind of tracers for which you also get
good distances that are the cf8s that
are presetting stars
uh they are a bit older so there is a
chance that they already drifted away
from their from their birthplace but on
the other end we know something like
more than three thousand in the Milky
Way which in principle helps us to to
you know properly locate those power
arms and you can see here on the
distribution in in a specific direction
that the the distribution of the
cepheida speaks that are the black the
black the black curves that matches
quite well with with the power arm
models of read from measures so probably
it's a good tool to to also uh identify
those poweramps and I will skip some
details because I guess I have no time
so here are the cephades located here
and uh just uh very quickly you can see
that there are some areas from here it's
not very easy to see but you see some
blank areas in the in this in here it's
just probably at the at the bottom of
this like con cone structures there is a
big cloud that prevents from seeing
what's behind and then we we don't
detect the stars in this region and that
will have an importance later
so well if we talk about spirals we
start with let's say the logarithmic
spiral and if you if you try to make it
a bit easier you go in a slightly
different space where you expect to have
linear features in the in the Theta and
logarithm of radio of space where radius
0 R is a distance from the galactic
center
and uh Theta is just the angle you have
a you start somewhere you have a
reference and you turn around the Milky
Way and then you define an angle that
way and then the ID is well you you try
to use Disney which is a
dimension in the dimension native
addiction algorithm to try to identify
groups of cephades
hoping it will do better than and
especially not by us like a human would
be
and then so that's what I did and only
using two Dimensions the coordinates and
that's what it looks in the top left in
the Disney space and then in the Disney
space it will be completely gray and
then I use hdb scan which is a customer
algorithm to identify these groups
without human biases and some of them
are just bogus some are real groups
hopefully and when you return to the no
the the let's say normal space the
original space you fight quite some
linear features that you expected and
also again these Burgers like the orange
or the pale blue here those are so I
guess I have no time to explain why but
we can chat later
uh and then if you return on the
original coordinates and you you already
see features that look like Spiral arms
and then you can on this linear plate
you can do a linear fit
and then you obtain this like olives
segments on the spiral arms they fit
quite well with other methods except
this one which was probably completely
wrong
and maybe the good thing is that you
detect new features for instance this
one that has not been seen by any others
so I think it's a pretty pretty uh I was
actually positively impressed by the
results I'm not stressed
thank you so I had to cut a lot but we
can chat later thanks a lot